Melania Trump is slowly easing into her
role as first lady after moving into the
White House she's met with foreign
leaders including South Korean president
moon jae-in and his wife last week a new
Smithsonian Channel series called first
ladies revealed offers a
behind-the-scenes look at the wives of
our presidents it examines their many
roles including calming the nation
during times of crisis at times of war a
first lady's rule changes Laura Bush is
far from the first to discover this
Edith Wilson in World War one Lady Bird
Johnson during Vietnam Barbara Bush the
Gulf War of 1991 each of these and more
have risen to the challenge
these kind of events are what tests your
resolve and certainly someone like Laura
Bush drew from her inner reserves of
strength
Annina McBride a featured expert in
first lady's revealed served as chief of
staff for first lady Laura Bush she also
worked as an assistant to President
George W Bush and as director of White
House personnel and Amina McBride joins
us now good morning good morning thanks
for having me this is such a great
series that we all got a chance to sort
of get a glimpse at and you they talked
about it how first lady's personal style
can sort of make an imprint how well
there's a lot of power to style and you
have an example of someone like Jackie
Kennedy who really still in our history
is so iconic and the fact that she
really understood the power of images
and as a young first lady again prior to
her being first lady the average age was
49 years old and here she was a 31 year
old first lady and that impe impact of
the youthful side of our country was
really important with young kids in the
White House yeah they also talked about
the series talks about how she initially
had the clothes made overseas in the
head to appear that wasn't a Chanel suit
it was a knockoff that's right it with
the design coming from a part of the
world where she was very comfortable and
again first lady's have to be themselves
and she had been schooled in in France
you love the French language she loved
the influence of that style and how that
could apply to our American Way of life
you were in the White House on 9/11 we
had Laura Bush tell me about that moment
you think of Laura Bush just so quiet
and reserved what was it like working
with her and what was that day like in
particular well at the time of 9/11 I
was working on the president's side so I
was working for President Bush and mrs.
Bush of course I knew that she had gone
up to the hill for the first time to do
a briefing to the education and
Workforce Committee on a topic that she
was very comfortable with this was nine
months into the administration she was
just finding her voice she had just held
the National Book Festival they just had
their first state dinner and she was
really comfortable now in her role
and then this happens I mean evacuating
the White House all of us that have
worked there and I've worked there since
the Reagan days you never think that
you're going to be vulnerable you think
this is a safe place to be and we
realized being under contac just how
vulnerable we were it was interesting to
see though the shifting role her role
after 9/11 as compared to the presidents
at the time and I think and in this
series that's one of the things I've
said you know that you these are the
unexpected things that can happen you
can have so many issues that you want to
work on but things that happen outside
of your control and how do you respond
to them that's what the country looks
for in your character and in this case
with Laura Bush she did draw from her
deep inner reserves of strength in that
quiet strength that you had mentioned
that really helped a combination that
was in total shock and grief we know
back in November Melania Trump had
announced cyberbullying right he's
something close to her heart do you
think that's the right topic for her
what advice would you have for her well
I do think it's important to look at the
segment you had right before this with
Lisa talking about the impact of social
media on children and on families in
general so I would say that Lisa is one
of the experts that the first lady can
draw from because that is one of the
things of being in the White House you
can call on all the best experts to help
inform you and really to roll out an
initiative that's going to have an
impact one might imagine the President
and First Lady having some interesting
discussions about social media these
days but you mentioned Jackie Kennedy
before and taking some of the criticism
these sort of elite criticism Nancy
Reagan did sure as well right so how did
I how did the huddle first ladies handle
that well it's hard you know and how
mrs. Reagan handled it of course she
came in wanting to again at another time
in our history of sort of uplifting
American spirits we were going through a
recession we our hostages had been held
and this was her way of bringing an
elegance and a feeling of pride back to
the White House and the thing is of
course you know the the roll out of her
clothes and the China it just and it was
hard but how did she respond to it a
year later she made
and stuff self-deprecating way made fun
of herself and self-deprecating way by
dressing in hand-me-down clothes and
singing at a major white tie White House
event so if you're advising the first
lady now I mean for her to sort of get
comfortable in that role what do you I
mean she's there six months in now what
do you what are you telling her well I
think one of the things is of course you
always want to tell first ladies be
yourself and what we saw in the world
stage which was the the longest period
of time that we actually saw mrs. Trump
in public on those nine days on their
foreign visit and this is where it was
my sense of it was you know being a
global citizen being born in a foreign
country only being an American citizen
for ten years speaking different
languages is where she really showed a
an amazing comfort level and I think did
a great job representing the country and
being on the global stage
we sometimes forget how influential
first ladies can really be they really
are leaders and they're Patriots and the
one thing you'll never have them speak
out against their husbands in public
what they say privately may be different
yeah but that is the one thread that
combines all of them together
I need a McBride thank you for joining
thank you for having me first ladies
revealed airs Sundays on Smithsonian
Channel it's owned by the Smithsonian
Institute and Showtime a division of CBS